Is this the roof of a majestic Beirut mosque?
No, it’s a Cheesecake Factory in Peoria, Arizona.
Is this a fifteenth-century Italian beach house?
No, it’s the entrance to an epicurean world of
fine dining, courtesy of the Cheesecake Factory.
And is this the Eye of Sauron, or perhaps some
portal to another dimension? Not exactly, though
there is a transcendental quality to the Chocolate
Caramelicious Cheesecake Made With Snickers.
Some describe these establishments
as excessive, pretentious, tacky,
tasteless, chaotic, soulless,
obnoxious, and overwhelming.
But the Cheesecake Factory is misunderstood.
Those giant Egyptian columns conceal complexity,
authenticity, and, oddly enough, humility.
Sponsored by Brilliant (and
Brilliant only). Learn math,
science, and computer science the intuitive
way with the link in the description.
By size, the Cheesecake Factory
may not look all that impressive.
With about 200 locations, it ranks only fifteenth
among American casual dining restaurants.
There are seven and a half times as many
Applebee’s and four times as many Olive Gardens.
But watch what happens when we
compare revenue per location.
Suddenly, the Cheesecake Factory
sits in a league of its own.
Its average restaurant generates 11
million dollars a year — 76% more
than second-place Texas Roadhouse
and 60% more than P.F. Chang’s.
Like In-N-Outs, they may be relatively
few and far between — in fact, there are
fewer Cheesecake Factories than In-N-Outs — but
each one is a certified money-printing machine.
Put differently: that’s eleven hundred dollars per
square foot — more than Kay Jewelers
made selling wedding rings in 2014.
Avocado eggrolls are apparently a better
route to riches than literal diamonds.
There are two main ingredients
to this incredible success.
First, this is what demand looks
like at a typical restaurant over
the course of the day, from Chili’s to Chipotle.
During lunch and dinner, customers are easy to
find. In fact, you don’t find them. They find you.
This, on the other hand — the
period between about 2 and 5pm — is
every restaurant’s nightmare. Three
hours during the middle of the day,
every day, that are almost as
unprofitable as 8 in the morning.
During this window, location is
extremely important. Customers
will stop by, but only if it’s convenient.
The solution? Many Cheesecake
Factories are located in or near malls.
Afternoon shoppers guarantee a steady flow
of foot traffic during this lull — solving
one of the greatest challenges in the
industry — sharp fluctuations in demand.
The other ingredient, of
course, is its legendary menu.
What started as one page in the
1970s has now grown to twenty-one,
with 13 categories, 26 sub-categories,
and — wait for it — 250 unique items.
What you’re looking at here is a condensed
version, without the descriptions, prices,
international translations, company story,
disclaimers, trademark symbols, and, yes,
full-page cheesecake advertisements
usually scattered throughout.
Neither does what you’re seeing
include the separate kids,
happy hour, gluten free, or quote
“low calorie” “SkinnyLicious” menus.
At 6,000 words and with an estimated
reading time of 30 minutes,
the real menu is more treatise than Tweet.
From here, opinions quickly diverge.
A deep, though unspoken schism
divides the cheesecake discourse.
After extensive ethnographic
research and a few clogged arteries,
I’ve identified two customer archetypes.
The first sees in the “darn-good”
3,000-calorie “Factory Nachos with
Spicy Chicken” incredible value — a hearty dinner
and lunch the next day — all from an appetizer.
From Italian to Mexican, Chinese, and American
cuisine, there’s truly something for everyone.
Where else can grandma order a Cobb salad
and grandson a “cheeseburger spring roll”?
The other half sees a heart
attack waiting to happen.
In this strange alternate universe, even a salad
can set you back nineteen hundred calories.
The average American is advised to eat no
more than 20 grams of saturated fat per day.
The “Classic Basque Cheesecake” contains
88 — nearly four and a half days worth.
And if all those calories don’t
cause a heart attack, they argue,
the architectural hyperstimulation will.
The gigantic portions. The
21-page menu. The collision of
Egyptian columns and Californian
palms. It’s all just… too much.
To this group, the Cheesecake Factory represents
not just gross opulence but the only
thing worse: unjustified opulence.
They imagine the company as three Olive
Gardens in a trench coat — a transparent,
clumsy attempt to make a corporate chain
appear more sophisticated than it clearly is.
They enjoy the same Very Cherry Ghirardelli®
Chocolate Cheesecake …but with a certain
hesitation, from a psychological distance,
and with a tinge, perhaps, of smugness.
There’s simply no way all two-hundred and
fifty dishes were meticulously crafted,
nevermind freshly prepared. Therefore, the
large menu must indicate a lack of taste,
a cynical emphasis on quantity over quality.
…Except, here’s the thing: they were meticulously
crafted. And they are freshly prepared.
Somewhere between restaurants 1 and
200, likely after going public in 1992,
the Cheesecake Factory should have succumbed
to the natural process of ‘corporatization’.
It should have shed its quirky SoCal
personality and joined the homogenous,
soul-less heap of Olive
Gardens and Rainforest Cafes.
These corporate ghosts may retain superficial
vestiges of their former glory — Olive Garden’s
shallow commitment to “hospitaliano” — but
inside they’ve become generic, cheap imitations.
Would you like your mass-produced, microwaved soup
served with a French beret or a Mexican sombrero?
Submerged in this sea of same-y brands,
who can blame these critics for assuming
the same of the Cheesecake Factory?
The company doesn’t scold those who scoff in its
direction. Nor does it do much
to advertise its authenticity.
If anything, the opposite.
You can certainly be forgiven for thinking food
from a self-described “factory” was mass-produced!
Shockingly, however, it’s really not.
Everything you see is made from scratch.
Not “scratch” with a wink. Really.
Starting at 6am each morning, chefs begin prepping
700 ingredients and 160 sauces, marinating each
piece of buffalo chicken, shredding each
block of cheese, and chopping each tomato.
And because everything is made to order, the
company will gladly accommodate all kinds of
customizations. Try ordering a Caesar
Salad without lettuce and be amazed.
The only exception is the cheesecake
itself, which is made in one of two
bakeries — in California and North Carolina
— and flown as far as Kuwait and China.
Now, does its hilariously large
menu allow the company to attract
more customers and thus generate more profit?
Of course! Nobody is claiming otherwise.
But every last one one of
those 250 meals are delicious.
And they aren’t chosen by focus
groups or in corporate boardrooms.
Instead, the founder, law school drop-out,
and former rock musician David Overton,
now 76 years old, personally approves each one.
Other companies pay lip service to inclusivity
with half-hearted low-calorie, gluten-free,
and vegetarian choices, only to
cut them when costs increase.
After all, rule number one when it
comes to profitability is: less is more.
Fewer options equals less complexity,
lower costs, and faster training.
In 2021, 60% of restaurants reported
reducing the size of their menus.
IHOP recently dropped a whole ten
pages. Dave & Busters went from 40
items to 15. Even McDonald’s
switched to a “limited menu”.
The Cheesecake Factory, on the other hand,
maintains its mind-boggling cornucopia of 250
choices, replacing but not removing a dozen
or so every six months to keep things fresh.
A few are practically sacred — like “Evelyn's
Favorite Pasta”, named after David’s mother,
and the “Original Cheesecake”
— unchanged since the 1940s.
Gaze into the surreal, dreamlike
abyss that is the Cheesecake Factory,
ponder its dizzying success,
and tell me: what do you see?
If the image staring back at you is that of an
insecure teenager sporting a briefcase and an
oversized suit, it’s only because the illusion
of carelessness was so seamlessly executed.
The Cheesecake Factory is
so confident in its taste,
freshness, and quality that it
rocks the oversized suit with ease.
It willingly, unnecessarily chooses to
expose itself to ridicule for our enjoyment.
It’s not a careless, chaotic, corporate
commodity masquerading as fine-dining.
It’s fine dining masquerading as a
careless, chaotic, corporate commodity.
Tragically, this modesty
has robbed it of its place
in the small pantheon of lovable corporations.
Now, is the Cheesecake Factory weird? Objectively.
But its weirdness is a product
of its role: a melting pot.
It lies at the intersection of blue and
white-collar America — a nice dinner out
for the working class, and a fun — if slightly
ironic — indulgence for the middle class.
Its low-calorie, gluten-free, and over forty
vegetarian choices scream “come one, come all”.
And its strange palate is the result of an
indiscriminate fusion of cuisines — from
“Tex Mex Eggrolls” to “Cheeseburger Spring Rolls”.
Finally, the Cheesecake Factory
is the ultimate American export.
Forget about the Statue of
Liberty or $20 million F-16s.
85 countries and territories host American
military bases. 19 are “Major non-NATO allies”.
But only the most privileged — a
small, elite circle of ten — have
the honor and distinction of hosting
a Cheesecake Factory — Canada, Mexico,
Bahrain, Kuwait, Qatar, Saudi Arabia,
the UAE, China, Hong Kong, and Macau.
These culinary outposts — shining beacons
of American decadence, multiculturalism,
and abundance — are as effective an ambassador
as any of its embassies, movies, or pop songs.
Today’s sponsor, Brilliant, offers a
no less impressive or diverse menu of
courses — on everything from programming
to probability, physics, and calculus,
so you can learn new skills, explore a
potential career, or just stay sharp.
With Brilliant, you can calculate the
probability you’ll enjoy the Cinnabon
Cinnamon Swirl Cheesecake and fully appreciate
the beautiful geometry of the Tiramisu. After
your meal, you’re going to need to read
up on the Mammalian Caloric Intake lesson.
Brilliant makes learning fun and
interactive by teaching through
application. You’ll solve puzzles, riddles,
and play games rather than memorizing facts.
Click the link on screen now —
Brilliant.org/PolyMatter — to
start your free, unlimited
30-day free-trial. The first
200 people to do so will also get 20%
off their annual premium subscription.
Go, pick what interests you
most and start learning today.